okay was 30-pot sir we always have a
really tight game I think the last time
we played I fell for that stalemate I
can see it right now I'm having
flashbacks oh the last time we played
now make sure your mutant the stream
don't you dare be listening in while we
are playing I always listen back that's
why I have that little time stamp in the
bottom right so you can easily click on
the videos tab on Twitch
let's go d4 wait you're talking I could
hear it already some people are thinking
what you're talking move your pieces I
know I know how you feel okay Knight f3
collide approach I want to gather some
more information okay I'm done gathering
I'm gonna go with this alright how's
that what do you call this what opening
is this what is a3 indicate anybody know
who were two famous chess players who
employed this a3 move you could discuss
that in the twitch chat I'm not going to
reveal the answer I could give some
hints though one starts with the P the
other starts with a K okay let's chop
how will there be a recapture efore
drops a pawn don't you dare do that
Knight takes bishop takes so what's the
plan the plan here is going to be to
baby step it and it may seem a bit
foolish to do that because guess who was
maybe a bit upset with things the dark
square bishop but that's okay where does
my light square bishop belong here seems
like a good one seeing how this night
could be off the board in a second in h7
is a bit more vulnerable
let's get castled I'm not sure what
to do and I have to definitely
definitely definitely take into account
that my opponent is a fast player and is
a player who has beaten me many a times
and he will beat me again
if I don't move quick so let's go with E
for now all right let's do it now that I
have support now that I could play it
safely without the loss of material
that's always nice right I want to lose
any puns I'll pawn push here that gonna
be anything exciting let's play here
rook d1 a4 a5 get my Bartman my my bark
where did that come my bark my dark
square bishop I fumble with that okay my
bishop is moving a bishop that moves on
the dark square is a bark I guess
rook to d1 this is not good if I'm
already fumbling on my words those war
zones are going to be ridiculous okay I
like this and the primary reason is to
engage with this Queen side structure
with a 5 what else might be the reason
to clamp down on b5 and well there might
be some no there wouldn't really be a
knight maneuver to b6 that's a bit too
far-fetched so I want to maintain these
two pawns right here and actually
another thing I'm just having a
flashback of an over the board game I
had from this position where I was
allowed on the black side this by the
way is a little bit reminiscent of a
grünfeld but anyhow that flashback I had
was one where I was able to pivot on f4
and I think that that turned out to be a
good sort of a good thing to do so I
want to keep my darts for bishop around
here but what is going on with this it's
structural change d5 past pawn is c4
gonna be played it might but I think
what's the scoop here what's going on
this is a scene
a serious move a critical move that's
what I mean by that this Bishop what's
going on with them what's going on with
this bishop he's biting in Iraq isn't he
if there's anything there this has to be
played I think this might already be a
necessity can you believe that that this
might be a must move in order for black
to get play with their pieces and their
Queen and the rook this Knight now that
this is a passed pawn this Knight
I think definitely wants to get here or
maybe here but again this move is gonna
have to be played otherwise now or never
if you don't play c4 I might be playing
c4 and I have connected passed pawn and
these two pawns this a4 c4 structure
will clamp down on any potential pawn
break that black might have in the form
of a six and B five I can even add an
additional protector of this b v square
and my opponent is investing a ton of
time and I don't know what the scoop is
I think this is actually turning out to
be one of those boa constrictor like
positions where the more black tries to
wriggle out the more difficult life
becomes because guess what with the
center now close guess where the action
will take place any guesses on that one
if you guessed on the wings you're right
I really didn't allow too much time to
think on that one but anyhow Center
closed means you should be looking to
play on the wings on either the ABC
files or fgh files there is notation on
the the sides of the board if you are
super new to the game so and these are
files the things that goes up and down
these are ranks left and right anyhow c4
I think I do that and then think later
move first things second I guess on this
one now maybe this night is having
getting the bright idea to come to this
f4 square I could always take that into
account with g3 and this Bishop what is
it doing he's got her he's definitely
got to come back here I don't see that
this move is going to be coming anytime
soon
in the meantime what is my plan there
might actually be something to say with
this rook by way of a3 and then swinging
over
laterally swinging over along this third
rank
okay this Bishop is going to be coming
back here the nights gonna be playing
here and I'm going to be doing what well
sensing that this night bite might play
here I think I might want to try for
these moves let's try this and actually
another thing is I'm allowing for night
2 h2 which i think is a very important
thing to be taking into account actually
now I don't really need to be doing that
well what's the scoop here my
LightSquared Bishop is a big dummy
of my two bishops this is the one that
needs more work so how can you get them
doing more work I'm going to do a move
like this get ready to play my Bishop to
e2 my knight to h2 my knight to h2
definitely in response to Bishop c8 this
would be a pretty annoying pin okay
let's come here
time to maneuver 40 seconds my opponent
is kicking it into the higher gear that
I figured they would Oh what's going on
with the knight scary Knight moves okay
don't you dare lose this if anything you
better went on time that's my that's my
plan at the very least you better win on
time white okay I want to trade light
square bishop but I'm not seeing that
happen any time soon let's play here I
guess the rook is gonna play here and
then f5 but oh no no no oh wait what's
going on what's going on with this move
I could take or can i okay
I'm gonna try and hang on to this guy
hang on to him there might be pawn push
but it's not without weakening h6 what's
this Queen up to you got to go somewhere
else Queen she's got to go back home
okay hey where's my rip belong right
here pressure on this pawn pressure on
this pawn pressure on everything defend
Knight f1 was another one I'm gonna do
that right now watching out for this
pawn push as well 23 seconds see how my
pawn is flying I knew that they would
start flying
oh this pawn is dead or is it I haven't
defended now g6 the knight hangs oh was
this trouble dark strip bishops off and
now this pond is live he's alive he's
ready to rumble here his pawns ready to
follow I know he's not let's break at
this structure somehow they don't have
any time to chop here and my rooks need
to do something else they're stupid
right here as long as my knight sits
there aren't they they play Queen here
let's do it pressure on a rook in a pond
oh oh I got the Pawnee the Queen is
incredibly active now this is a tough
spot for Team black less than ten
seconds let's just come over here cleans
off soon get the ladies off please can
we just I could have taken on c5 as well
let's just make sure this where is this
night going not gonna hurt me Izzy just
take care they'll never suspect that one
there's no time I could have done
anything at that point but tight game I
figured my opponent would definitely
catch up on time they were down to a
minute thirty I had a big oh I didn't
mean to do that I had a big lead
timewise but yeah good game let me go
back through this one yes let's
definitely go back through the
okay what in the world is the scoop and
by the way I was not looking at the
responses to that hint that I gave out
earlier about this a3 move two guys
behind that a3 move are at least the two
guys or at least two guys Petrosian and
Kasparov okay we have this black is just
trying to play with the pieces have the
pieces what I mean by that is have the
pieces occupy well no that's that's
actually a bad way to phrase it
the pieces are trying to control the
center and not the pawns if the pawn
recaptured okay you could say black is
controlling the center with the pun or
at least a pawn is helping control the
center but now it's more just the bishop
in the night that are preventing white
from expanding right away in one stroke
here e to to e4 two pawns side-by-side
in the center so there's a little bit of
a baby step going on with the e3 move
and only later once it's supported we
have that advanced right because I was
just rattling this off quickly right
here if I do it
there's Knight takes pawn takes Bishop
takes pawn so let's not do that and what
do we do so this is the typical strike
you have to be aware of this on the
black side you can't you have to
challenge this center in some way and
that's exactly my opponent is doing I
think it's safe to say at this point
right here white stands better after
this pawn push I think this is too too
valuable now granted I did not really
put it to fantastic use my opponent does
not have any King sight weaknesses but
this d5 pawn in just so many instances
acts as a what it acts as a great asset
in a King and pawn endgame in particular
going stripping the position down to
something as simplified as just kings
and pawns that connected past pun is
it's priceless and I mean there's just
so many other one other positions as
well the more
or becomes simplified the the more that
this past pun increases in value I think
so I I think we have to back up here
because I don't know about this pond
push what might be something else though
how about this how about this how about
instead of instead of pushing right away
if you're gonna play this move how about
at least allow for the black pieces to
be making use of the c5 squared now this
this ID will come not with out allowing
your Queen to be subjected to an attack
maybe by a white rook on the C file but
my point here is to still go with this
'if I've move but capture first CD CD
after E 5 if I'm playing d5 well guess
what
it could be making use of this c5 square
Queen Knight Bishop of those three the
knight is probably the one most excited
about getting there so that's just a
really I think a simple adjustment to be
making what a world of difference it
would make to not have both C pawns on
the board in other words because that's
exactly what happened try to visualize
these these next and soon moves that I'm
just going to be voicing I can't I can't
move them but it's C takes the C takes D
or in other words it's like the C pawns
have been removed after those captures
and so if you're able to visualize this
position right here without the see
pawns on the board c5 is available for
the black pieces that's my main point
and I think it'd be a much more
difficult struggle black was really
having to make some defensive moves I
think over on this King side after the
Center was closed up and I guess maybe
not actually just play rook here first
and then this pawn push although maybe
I'm getting the the bishops off in time
so it's kind of tough and if the light
square bishops are off this Knight is
going to be like
this f5 square it's a great square to
begin with and it's all the more
appealing because it's putting pressure
on this block hey there and the bishop
which isn't the best block hater of this
past pod but it's gonna have to do it's
better than a queen or a rook the knight
would be the number one guy that you
would want there but anyhow capture
first on d4 here and only then play that
e five move all right let me close let's
do another one